let's take you through some of the
tributes and there have been many many
thousands coming in these are some of
the best known we've got Gary lineker
who's tweeted Pele has died the most
Divine of footballers and joyous of men
he played a game only a few chosen ones
have come close to three times he lifted
the most coveted gold trophy in that
beautiful yellow shirt he may have left
us but he'll always have footballing
immortality R.I.P Pele
Jeff Hurst tweeted I have so many
memories of Pele without doubt the best
footballer I ever played against with
Bobby Moore being the best footballer I
ever played alongside for me Pele
Remains the greatest of all time and I
was proud to be on the pitch with him
R.I.P Pele and thank you that from Sir
Jeff Hurst the former England player
Michael Owen tweeted a sad day for
football around the world Brazilian
Legend and three times World Cup winner
Pele has passed away at the age of 82
rest in peace Edson Arantes do nasimento
that's uh of course pele's full name
Usain Bolt simply tweeted a sporting
Legend
rest in peace King Pele
and Cristiano Ronaldo posted on
Instagram my deepest condolences to all
of Brazil and in particular to the
family of Mr Edson Arantes de nacimento
a mere goodbye to the Eternal King Pele
will never be enough to express the pain
that currently Embraces the entire world
of football Ronaldo continued by saying
an inspiration for so many millions say
reference from yesterday today forever
the affection he always showed for me
was reciprocal in every moment we shared
even from a distance he will never be
forgotten and his memory will live on
forever in each of us football lovers
rest in peace
King Pele